hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the losers section of the Julius bear
generation cup division one uh it is
Dennis slazovic versus alares Ja and
whoever wins this will face Magnus
Carlsen in the Grand Final now this is
the second game of their match and it's
a truly an amazing one because one
player uh or a better barrier let's not
say anything let's just enjoy the game
so of course you know alireza Dennis
lazavik he is a 17 year old he's from uh
uh Belarus and um uh he well he's
obviously very strong he already
defeated uh amitabhattabahi defeated
Wesley so he defeated the another in in
this event and now only alireza stands
between him and Magnus Carlsen and the
Grand Final so let's see uh how he does
here uh he has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6 sorry
D5 in this game by alireza C for C6 and
now Knight to F3 we have Knight to F6 E3
and Bishop to F5 uh we ignite the C3 and
not just closing the structure nicely
with E6 while the light Square Bishop
has been developed so at the Shell of
defense of the of the slab we have
Knight to H4 going after the bishop
right away it is the most common way to
treat this Bishop T for F3 Bishop to G6
and now Knight captures on G6 uh sorry
uh first uh Bishop to D2 was played uh
Bishop to E7 and now Knight captures and
G6 H captors and here uh almost
exclusively and when I say almost
exclusively I really mean that Queen to
B3 is the only move put pressure on the
center also puts pressure on Black's
undefended B7 Pawn but Dennis played
Queen to situ and it has only been
played twice before and only once by a
grand master in the 2017 World The Blitz
championship by Ahmed Ahli who also won
his game so let's see what he prepared
here and in that game uh A6 was played
but here we have Ponte A5 by alireza and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game of course he wants
to stop on to B4 as one always should
and now Pawn the age for expansion on
the king side we have the characters on
c for Bishop captures and Knight to D5
while it is a queen side castles and now
Pawn to A4 alireza wants to play Pawn
day three and create a permanent
weakness so A3 and now Knight to D7 we
have pawned the E4 chasing away the
Knight Knight to F6 and now Bishop back
to A2 we have Pawn to B5 valdereza and
now Pawn to D5 of course the black king
is still in the center of the board so
you have to strike in the center C
captures with e captures e captures
Knight captures Knight captures and the
bishop captures on D5 we have Rook to C8
now looks terrible for Dennis but after
Bishop to C3 it's very hard to find the
move for alireza and also I mean look at
those Bishops those Bishops are
absolutely magnificent sure you're gonna
have to squeeze in King to B1 but uh uh
you know you should do that either way
and now I know what you guys are
wondering is B for a possibility here
well uh one of the rare cases where it's
not if you play B4 here then look at
this eight characters Bishop captures
and now Rook H the E1 check Bishop back
to E7 or King to f8 doesn't really
matter uh because then of course uh you
will also be able to uh well if you play
King to fade the bishop captures on B4
comes with checks so you don't want to
allow that so instead after Bishop back
to E7 you will play Bishop to E6 and
this bishop to E6 move is the critical
move in all of the lines that we're
going to check because it's such a such
a wild game and now you cannot capture
the bishop you capture the bishop Queen
captures and G6 with the check and now
everything falls apart you can see that
the bishop and queen are doing a very
good job here also you lose the rook and
so on and so on so what you will have to
do after Bishop to E6 is play something
like Rook to C7 to defend your knight
here but even that doesn't work just
Bishop captures on D7 and after Rook
captures you will play Queen captures
and A4 and now black is completely tied
down yeah you cannot move the Rook um as
it's pinned to the king you cannot move
the queen because then The Rook hangs uh
you cannot move the bishop so there's
there's really no move you can play here
you can't even move the king because
then you lose the Rook so there's no
move no move for black here uh so B4
although a fine idea does not work here
between the C7 uh by alireza and now
comes Rook H the E1 here uh you should
not wait with King to B1 King to B1 is
just straight out winning uh but it's
sort of a move that you you know you
don't uh find against a player like
alireza because you just don't think it
it's working point is that after any
move that black makes let's say make
Knight to B6 because it's a move you
really want to make again this bishop to
E6 move uh completely shatters Black's
defenses now you either lose a material
here or you or you still cannot capture
because of the same idea and if you play
something like Rook to d8 which of
course seems like a good idea you want
to trade down then just capture captures
and Rook to D1 first you get in another
free move Queen to A8 and now Bishop
captures on G7 you can play this you
don't have to play this if you Rook to
G8 you can even play Bishop to D4
because now the Knight is saying so you
don't care about your bishop and the
black is just completely destroyed here
so instead after Queen to C7 he did not
go for King to B1 he first played Rook H
the E1 which is still okay but only okay
because now alireza plays Knight to F6
he defends he attacks the bishop here
Queen to E2 now okay this uh sort of
paralyzes the black queen because Queen
captures an E7 would happen and alireza
just plays King to fade you cannot
Castle uh still Queen captures 97 so
alireza goes King to f8 and now King to
B1 but now it's not as potent alireza
goes Rook captures on H4 and with this
move alireza again completely blunders
the game but Dennis misses it
uh he plays Bishop to A2 which is a very
nice move but Bishop J5 ends the game on
the spot the queen can never move the
queen has to guard the bishop here on E7
so after he played Bishop to A5 where do
you move the queen of course you have to
move the queen somewhere and now you
kick away The Rook once The Rook moves
doesn't really matter where now you have
all sorts of nasty discoveries on the
queen like Bishop captures and F7 and
that's it if Queen day seven now you can
simply play Queen to E6 followed by
Bishop captures and G6 and queen to F7
Checkmate so everything is winning here
for Dennis but he played Bishop to A2
again the position is much much better
for him but now alireza does get B4 in
so a capture some B4 and now Queen to B7
hoping to bust open the position here we
have Rook to H1 so of course now you
have to react to this The Rook is
hanging Rook captures an H1 Rook
captures and now Knights the G8 uh if
you if you don't do this let's say you
play something like Bishop captures on
B4 then it's a pretty deadly Rook to h8
check you have to block and now Queen to
D2 uh there's no move for black yeah if
you capture here Queen to D6 is deadly
if you don't capture then you just win
the free Bishop with check and the
Checkmate the black king and if you just
go back it still doesn't matter now you
go Rook H7 you go after the G7 pawn and
after something like Knight to F6 you
can simply captures captures and I know
you guys forgot about our good friend
the bishop now you win the black queen
captures captures and captures uh sorry
in captors and captures and now it's
queen against the rook and Bishop okay
you will have to work for your meal a
little bit uh but not too much as Queen
D7 also picks up the Rook so after a
rook captures an H1 Knights the G8 right
away but it is uh he's much worse here
so he has to be very careful on to B5
now B4 is no longer a Target we have
Queen to B6 and now Queen to E5
threatening Checkmate and you cannot go
Bishop to F6 if you go Bishop F6 Bishop
B for check and there's nothing here if
Bishop back the seven dangerous Queen
captures on E7 Knight captures and
rooked h8 Checkmate a beautiful queen
sacrifice Checkmate as the night is now
pinned so after Queen D5 Rook characters
on C3 biologists at this is how he
defends against mate Queen captures and
now Queen captures on B5 so okay he uh
comes back into the game a little bit
but he's still down the exchange and
lasavik of course uh forces a queen
trade Queen to see it check Queen to E8
and now Queen capture Sunny ape King
captures and now Rook the AHA forcing
the king into passivity King to f8 and
now Bishop the C for now he will start
bringing his King into the game and
slowly but surely a secure more space
and then win the game as he is up
material so alireza says all right I
can't really allow this bishop to just
pick up the Free Pawn so let's trade
pawns but Lazer says Nope upon the B3
that pawn will remain there a permanent
weakness we have Pawn to G5 and now King
the A2 we have Bishop to B4 while it is
a rook to H5 now going after the pawn
here we have Bishop back D7 defending
the pawn and now King to B1 we have
Knight to H6 Bishop to D3 and now King
to G8 with Rook to H1 and now Pawn to G4
trying to uh give his Knight at least
some squares as the bishop is keeping it
uh trapped there so of course F4 you
don't allow it now uh Bishop to D6 goes
after the pawn pawn to G3 defends the
pawn and now just King to f8 now uh then
he says all right your Bishop is stuck
here guarding this Pawn the Knight is
stuck you're guarding this Pawn uh now
it's time to really activate all of my
pieces and my king So Rook to E1 stops
the king from entering the game Knight
to G8 with Bishop to F5 going after the
pawn and now Knight to F6 is defending
uh we have Rook the E3 and now Pawn to
G6 chasing away the bishop Bishop the C8
and now Bishop to C5 by playing some
moves uh attacking The Rook here we have
Rook to D3 and now Bishop to B4 and all
of a sudden you kind of get this idea
that maybe uh Dennis did not play this
uh you know as best as he could because
now uh okay the Knight has to be here
regarding this pawn and the bishop has
to be here guarding this Pawn or
anywhere on this diagonal so black will
not be playing for a win but how is
white to play for a win that's also the
question Rook to D4 Bishop to C5 we have
rooked to C4 and now Bishop to F2 now
all it is it goes after the king side
pawns uh Rook the C3 defending and now
Knights to E4 attacking The Rook ended
the pawn here and now you have to play
Rook to C6 you just have to give up the
pawn and then pick up the G4 Pawn but
Dennis wanted to uh sort of keep
everything in the game he played Rook to
D3 but now comes Pawn to F5 now he can
no longer capture on G4 but he can no
longer avoid losing material on the king
side so this is now really bad upon the
B4 he does start advancing his past B
Pawn but now there is a place Knight
captures on G3 with Bishop to B7 at
least now okay you will be controlling
this diagonal so when the fast Pawn
starts marching forward you have this
covered but not really Knights the E4
and now all of a sudden the bishop
covers G3 and G1 and the Knight is
preventing the Bishop from guarding G2
so this Pawn is definitely becoming a
queen what can uh Dennis do about this
he starts by capturing an A3 but now
Pawn to G3 we have Rook A6 going after
the G6 Pawn alireza simply defends it
King to G7
uh King to C2 uh G2 and now Rook to A1
he will have to give up his Rook for the
pawn we have Pawn to uh G1 Queen Rook
captures and G1 and Bishop captures and
G1 and now it's all of a sudden alireza
who is up a full night uh it's okay with
uh perfect play maybe you can draw this
if you can snatch at least one of the
pawns uh King to D3 Knight to D6 goes
after the bishop Bishop D Bishop to C6
King to F6 with King to E2 Bishop to D4
and now King to F3 with Bishop to C3 and
now Pawn to B5 uh you know where there's
a past Pawn there's a chance uh only
another very big one Bishop to D4 now as
you have a light Square Bishop you you
you stand no chance of overcoming that
dark Square B6 Square talking to G3 King
to E7 and now King to F3 uh with King 38
King to G3 now King to C7 King to F3 and
now King to B6 with King to G3 uh King
to C5 5 now we have came to F3 and only
now Bishop to F6 you have to play this
G5 move otherwise there is no way to
make progress but progress will be made
make no mistake there so Bishop to D7
now okay if you uh well yeah well the
pawn is defended by the Knight so it
doesn't really matter Knight characters
on B5 the pawn is now lost Bishop to E8
goes after the G6 pawn and now Knights
the D4 check first king to E3 and of
course Pawn to G5 F captures Bishop
captures with check we have King to F2
and now King to D6 with Bishop to G6 uh
and now Pawn to F4 you can even give it
up because you still have a bishop and
Knight against the the bear King and of
course you know that is winning but
let's uh you know push it a bit further
first with Bishop to H5 now comes King
to E5 with King to G2 and now King the
E4 we have King to F2 and now Bishop H4
King to G2 and King to E3 we have King
to H3 Bishop to F6 and now King to G2
with Bishop to E5 and now Bishop to G4
and unfortunately for alireza there is
no way to actually Checkmate the white
king before giving up that uh Pawn for
the bishop here so Pawn to F3 check now
you have to give it up otherwise you get
a queen so Bishop captures Knight
captures and King to H3 and now you have
a standard uh Knight and uh Bishop
against a king which can be one I
checked the the table bases actually you
can win it in exactly 40 moves uh with
absolute best defense um uh from White
so let's see how aleriza does it we have
King to F4 and also you will see how how
it's done if if some of you for some
reason don't know how to do this I have
made a tutorial on this it will be the
first link in the description below uh
so if you don't know how to check me
with Bishop at night you know do cover
that King the G2 Bishop to D4 and now
either forces because uh of course you
know this you cannot Checkmate the
kingly in a light Square Corner if you
have a dark Square Bishop so the white
king will try to escape
these two squares and of course you want
the king either on A1 or an h8 talking
to H3 we have Knight to G5 with check
King to G2 and now Knights the E4 so the
first part of the plan is forcing the
king to a corner where you can actually
Checkmate him King the H2 King to F3
King to H1 and not Knight the G3 check
now kicking G1 is taken now it's time
for the white king to start his journey
King to H1 Bishop to C5 with King to H3
Bishop to G1 now taking away the B the
the H2 Square King H4 now comes Knight
to the E4 taking away the G5 Square so
King H5 if you go down the board doesn't
really matter you're still gonna play
Knight to G5 check King H4 and now of
course King to F4 and the the Knight Now
controls H3 so you're gonna have to go
to H5 so that's why H5 right away King
to F4 now comes King to G6 of course you
will now try to run away to this corner
if possible so Knights the G5 uh
stopping this King to F6 and Bishop to
C5 now the bishop and Knight are
preventing the white king from escaping
also the king covers this so King 6 with
Bishop to D4 forcing the king of the
board King to H5 and King to F5 King H4
and Bishop to have to check the bishop
and knight and king now Force the white
king up the board King H5 Bishop to E1
King the H6 and now Knight the E6 again
it's the exact same maneuver over and
over and over King H5 Knights the G7
check the bishop prevents this the king
covers this and the Knight forces the
king of the board King H6 King to F6
King to H7 and now King to F7 uh King to
H6 with Bishop to D2 with check bishop
and Knight do again a very good job King
H7 Knight the E6 and he was in this
position and move 106 that then
islazovic resigned the game and what an
incredible victory for alireza firiza so
from that position where I said it will
take you 40 moves at uh get the job done
it took alireza 21 moves okay it's still
three more moves to Checkmate so uh so
how you do this actually after the only
move that is King to h8 uh one thing you
don't do is playing Knight of Fate now
it seems like it's Checkmate on the next
move but it's actually stalemated the
wild King has no moves so before you
actually do this final Final Touch uh
you have to waste the move that will
always be the case so you waste the move
Bishop E3 and now once King E7 H7 is
played now the Knight comes to f8 with
check that's the point Knight f8
checking h8 and Bishop to D4 will of
course be checkmate uh so very nicely
done by alireza and uh as he said uh I
think he said in an injury after the uh
after the match is the same thing with
alireza when he was starting out you
know he was strong but when he was
facing Wesley when he was facing Fabiano
he would also get winning positions but
then he would just lose uh you know it
comes uh with uh with the age and Dennis
is 17 now is already 20 years old so
it's quite the difference and you know
when you face a former 2800 like alireza
of course sometimes you you get a little
bit nervous uh but yeah Dennis played a
brilliant game he had all it is uh uh
beat beaten uh and he had him uh he he
had him in a lost position for like 30
moves but uh well it is a persevered and
in the end came out Victorious which
means alireza will be facing Magnus
Crossing in the Grand Final that is
happening today and we are in for some
uh for a real treat and we'll see if
allereza will be able to do a better job
than in in in the final where he lost
3-0 0 to Magnus Carlsen so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank crazier Dave Grizzly
chess festival.org.gg film office Jaron
Asher and rohantana for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
for those of you who still don't know
how to check me with bishop and Knight
first link in the description below see
you soon